is wanting it enough I'm going to answer
that question in today's episode of ask
Evan so not too long ago I made a video
on how to avoid procrastination I'll
link it up here and I got a comment from
one of the YouTube subscribers who wrote
in to say nobody procrastinate on
something they want to do so my response
to this is yes that's true but it's only
half of the equation see I'm kind of
like you when I want to do something I
have blinders on and I just go out and
do it and nothing gets my way if it's
something I really want to do I don't
like things hold me back but a lot of
people don't have that mindset and it's
important to look at both sides of the
equation so on the one side you have the
desire you have the walked right and
that's that has to be there if you don't
have that desire we don't really want it
to happen it's not going to happen but
on the other side you've got things like
your fears you've got your limiting
personal beliefs you've got your
environment so if I break that down if
you look at fears you know you're afraid
you're going to lose money you're going
to afraid you're going to fail you're
gonna you're afraid that of what people
are going to say about you you're
limiting beliefs you think that you
can't do it because you don't have an
education or you weren't born into the
right family or you're disabled or
you're an immigrant or whatever reason
you tell yourself you're holding
yourself back from work and then your
environment holds you back right your
friends your family your workspace all
of those things can hold you back from
achieving what you want so even though
you have the wand you have all these
things that hold you back whichever one
is higher that's what's going to take
charge so you can focus on building up
that wand as much as you want but if
it's still not enough to combine all of
those fears and limiting beliefs in the
environment that you're not going to
achieve your goal so you can either
focus on yes I want it I want it I want
and I want it but you can also focus on
reducing those other things it's the
first step is having an awareness
awareness that you're afraid of
something that it may not be actually
legit you're just afraid of it awareness
that you're holding yourself back
because you're limiting personal beliefs
awareness that your environment may not
be supporting and be conducive to you
achieving the goals that you want an
analogy is
if you want to make it as a baseball
player you want to be a professional
baseball player and a shortstop and all
your focus on is hitting and you're
hitting hitting hitting hitting you
could be the greatest hitter and make it
in as being a sharp stock but that's not
the only way to do it because defense
matters right because running matters
because game sense matters because
there's a lot of other factors that go
into you being a successful shortstop
and a major league level than just
hitting where if all you're focusing
inas the desire and the want then you're
just taking that hitting only approach
and that can get you there that can get
you over the hump but it's really really
really really hard to get there all
you're focusing is on the one we can
also figure out the rest of the equation
and reduce your fears and reduce your
limiting beliefs and create a more
supportive environment then you're much
more likely to cheat your goal belief so
my question for you today is what's your
thoughts is wanting it badly enough
enough I'd love to know what you have to
think leave in the comments below and
I'm gonna join the discussion thank you
so much for watching I'll see you soon